[Music]
this suit means something
it's not just protecting your body it's
protecting the universe ready captain
lightyear ready as i'll ever be to
infinity and
thank you
let's get everyone home
you need
my mistake has marooned us on this
strange planet
i need to make it right
hello buzz i am socks my mission is to
help you and i'm not giving up on my
mission i'm not giving up
great would you like a frosted snack
kick to celebrate negative
was like your mission log i plan to
finally finish the mission oh you're
talking to buzz no no one
here we go
are we going to crash no
well technically yes
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
what is going on
the what i hope you're ready for action
because all we needed was a pilot for
what we have to destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team do you
have munitions training partial so your
rookies oh boy we'd love to be rookies
through infinity are you trying to get
me to pull your finger don't
i think i need a bed oh no engage your
helmet that'll catch it
let's go finish the mission
we're being pursued by a
just a massive robot
we can do anything you're not shouting
my ear oh yeah
[Music]
hey what's that noise come on don't
break my cat he's purring he likes it
sucks do you like that i do
huh
[Music]
bye